some suggestions have a look at this
first one please mark is not an equation
you can't solve this thing you look at
any way up with an x equals something
because this thing is this thing's not
equal to anything like it's it's got X's
in it I'm never going to be able to get
rid of them that's okay I can still
simplify it what would I do any
suggestions yeah yeah very good when
you've got two fractions and they're
speaking different languages even if
they were just numbers like a half and a
fifth you need a common denominator
that's perfect okay and 12 will do it
for us so if we go question 1 what do I
have to do to the first fraction to make
its denominated 12 they are going to
multiply by 3 so of course if i multiply
the denominator by 3 like I can't just
go around mucking around with factions
comes on 12 because convenient to me
I've got to multiply bar what's
happening then you rather go do that
battery as well so I'll go x times stir
are you happy with that you see it's the
same fraction yeah multiply the top I
followed with fun what about the second
fraction what am I going to ulta pi by
this time yeah bye for now give me the
same denominator yeah so I'm going to
use some brackets here and that's four
times 30 and this is why we do this
because now I've got 12 and 12 these
guys can talk to each other now yeah
what if I got on the top 3 X take away
this guy
hey are you happy with that you see what
I in two fractions combined into one
okay I possibly could have taken this
and expanded it into the next step but I
want you to pause for a second put on
your teacher hat for a minute what do
you think this question is trying to
check for what skill do you think it's
making an Assessor alright so again okay
if you know what to do with this factor
right the fact is the critical thing
particularly the fact that it's got
these negatives in here easy spots are
not sure not be sure what you're doing
and maybe mr. Liddy ok so I'm leaving
that to an extra step 3 X take away when
I do your get rid of the factorization
four times 2x it is what happens with
these two here now yeah when you
multiply two negatives you're going to
get a positive and one times four is
just for every x all divided by 12 and i
only have a little thing i can do like
i'm going to collect like terms so 3
take away 8 negative 5 and I've done I
could I could write it in either honor I
can make it for take away 5 X that one
just fine it's the same it
you want to explain what do you I just
didn't know it was a difference that's
okay we'll just find help soon I x 12
okay so did you you had this this is
where we started so what did you do to
each day Karl and Hana might say that
again what did you x 12 so multiply this
by 12 and then multiply this by x that
is that what you did and I'm guessing
you got this yeah yeah maybe hey let's
just think that this because this is
this is someone this is why we're doing
it over and over there again Oh what is
what you got hey um I how did I know
that that was what was going to happen
at my years I had my partly okay but
mainly because have a thing about the
second um please closely closely look at
this line how sorry I closed my eye
closed the door on my hand today and
it's like Oh Bruce anyway have a look at
this line and compared to this one okay
look closely now do you see that this
and this are exactly the same thing I
just time to rearrange them a little bit
right like this fraction key is
identical to this fraction here they're
the same fraction yeah what why did I
change it why did I make it look
different yeah common denominator
amazonas after but the important thing
is this is the same fractions that in
exactly the same way that for instance a
half and three six and five tents all
the same fractions they just dress stop
differently does that make sense now
what you compare that to just one over
here you see this is no longer the same
fracture
1 i've started with fat it's the same
fraction x talk it's swell times bigger
right so it would be a little bit like
taking this fraction and if you multiply
by talk what a [ __ ] hops at 66 a half
clearly not the same number ok so I
can't change things here because that
would actually mean I get a different
answer all together and I'm making your
12 times bigger the reason I knew is
because if you make this too op times
bigger the fractional disappear ok and
this is very different to if you have a
look at the next question and what we're
confusing is when you've got an equal
sign in the middle right always picture
an equation is like a set of scales it's
a balance ok if you do something to one
side that's ok so long as you do
together because then you'll stay
balanced right you add stuff to both
sides you take away from both sides in a
work phone ok so that's why you can do
that if you've got an equation if for
instance the question said this if you
have
Yeah right you see he it's all look I
made this side bigger by a factor of 12
I think that side everything's fine okay
I got this exact question before if this
were n equals if it were an equation
then you can balance things out and you
can change things but here just like I
can't change this and I'd like to make
it tough times bigger just for the lulz
right now you're going to end up with a
different number yeah different letter
okay um number to be Prime when I spend
as much time when I think we're okay
with it can someone give me an otter
should be a nice round minus negative
yeah thanks a lot okay if you didn't get
near your term happy to come have a look
at you you put a bitter so well done if
you got it now have a look at this one
this is a bit sneaky we can have you
look at straight line I'm asking for an
equation right n equation now usually we
say most straight lines their equation
is in this form do you recognize it says
it's ringing some bells okay so if you
didn't know where to begin this is the
first thing I would have written down
with our solving this question the next
thing I think is well what do these
letters and numbers mean in particular
the M over B what are they signify in
the gradient these are y intercepts so
if I can work out those two things off
of the graph I'm there do you see that
let's do the easy one first which is
easy to work out great in a waiter wait
a sec you just read it off the graph
yeah and it is done okay so this is
going to be plus 3 do you agree that
that's what be actually is grain takes a
little work but not that much what do
you see as the gradient looks like to to
me you can pick any nice convenient
point like say there there's a nice
triangle all the points are unless grid
lines right you've got a rise and run so
the gradients going to be too you see
how I got that so this am in fact
these two I'm done happy times it'll
make sense so again let me just rehearse
that right I think about what's the
Christian asking looking for the
equation of a line every straight line
I've been working with is in this form
that's on the rep via another dollar she
should point out and maybe we just want
to think about what each of the pieces
means come to graph and check it online
does anyone want to clarify before i
move off that question yeah no I'm happy
feud is a doll you can ask me that if
you it occurs to you either
professionals all right now last one
mmhmm yeah I'll bring this back okay now
who got this one out hands up straight
don't tell me just eyes it's not totally
ears aren't just hands up who keep your
hand if you're confident do you have the
answer okay a good number of hands down
don't give me the answer yet I want you
to explain to me like what was the first
step that you did in having a look at
this and coming up with something like
the y cos 2x plus 3 so I want to give me
a suggestion was the first thing you
looked at okay you looked at that I
tried things out so I got something okay
you looked under x equals you so yeah
well there's obviously five when there's
no number like when is 0 is like so then
when it was one that was too
okay yes sir all right so you've said a
couple of things in there let me just
sort of grab on to firstly maybe the
easiest thing is every time you're going
across one right every time you go
across one you're going up to you see
that this is a cross and this is up and
down yeah so if you're going across and
then going up what does that number
signify which feature is that that's
called the grittier right like that's
run that's rise so I read straight off
that you have a great healer to actually
just like this question okay so a
grading of 2 i'm going to write down
this is number four the first thing I
see is M equals two okay and I'm reading
that off the fact if you had this on
your page I'd write like you know arrow
plus two arrow plus 2 etc that's what's
going on okay I need one more feature
you saw that in the previous question I
need the y-intercept which one of these
numbers is the y-intercept now it's
going to be fine how do we know that
it's fine what tools you it's fine the x
is 0 you can see the y-intercept right
right now that is where X is not equal
to 1 or negative 1 X equal to 0 right so
that's how we look up on the graph we
see three keep you in get a graph you
get values x equals 0 y plus 5 ok does
that make sense now this would have been
a harder question if I could I could
have taken off these first two data
points how would you have worked it out
if that's all you saw if this
what I have to
how would you have done it in this case
because you still can you've already
worked out the gradient it's still plus
two plus two how do you work out the
winder said now just give it a go now we
can write but the whole point of
mathematics is there are patterns and
you take advantage of them we don't have
to do to trial it out hey I'm doing give
a suggestion
very very good so it's a pattern going
forward and the pattern going backwards
are the same pattern just in opposite
directions right so if I'm adding to
going this way then if I actually want
not for three or two or one I want zero
then I've just got to go two steps
further I've got to subtract two and
subtract two again that's going to give
me five and you can kind of see it now
that I have the members there does that
make sense